each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
alright so my name is Aaron Smith and
it's my pleasure to introduce shinpei
Coughlin so shinpai is a recent graduate
of keio university and he's a leader at
Carnegie Mellon University where you're
working with Raj can't save Austin rajma
so interesting to talk today thanks for
introduction um so my name is shrimp a
title I am currently officially a
postdoc at the University of Tokyo but I
am visiting Carnegie Mellon University
so first of all I would like to thank
our own for giving giving me this
opportunity so today I'm talking about
the systems of the support for GP
accelerated applications so before the
tote let me introduce myself briefly
sorry cpht of care University a 2008 and
there so my PhD thesis is the rate i'm
scheduling and after that alam i moved
to university of tokyo and there i was
working on the operating system support
for interactive supercomputing then from
the pool last year I joined the CMU and
there I'm working on operating systems
for autonomous driving so my research
interests are in the areas of random
systems and particularly i am interested
in operating systems design and
implementation including CPU scheduling
gps scheduling network scheduling and so
on an application domains i have been
working on for instance humanoid a
multimedia and autumn ascribing but not
limited to these domains so i'll show
you a movie regarding the humanoid which
i have been developed involved in
development sorry the subtitle is it
written in Japanese but the humanoid is
reallocation and every action begins
with vision
based perception so every time it has to
work it has to recognize something so in
this case the human it has to recognize
what it has to interact with or who it
has to interact with and this is a huge
application which is composed of very
timing critical applications and of
course very fine-grained control is to
be provided as well so this is a
collaborative work with k University the
University of Tokyo and ice ice tea the
research institute in Japan so I have me
working in this project where I used to
develop the operating systems for the
humanoids okay so let me introduce
another movie which is about ultimus
driving that I am working on now the
autonomous driving is very similar to
humanoids in many senses because both
humanoid and autonomous driving
application are categorized into robots
so actually I am working with Professor
Roger ROG come up and he was that taken
care lead in the autonomous driving
project supported by GM so the team won
the diaper challenge in 2007 so this car
is called boss and so we actually
improving the functionality of this
autonomous driving car even for now so
you can see that of course it is
unmanned color so it can drive itself
deciding where to go what to do in a for
instance if the car encountered some
white line it has to stop and has to
check if no other cards are coming in
front ok it's just
the movie is a little bit long so I just
got here but basically what i have been
working in is something like this so
robot autumn as driving and so on the
real-time interactive applications but
from my viewpoint these applications
these systems look nice but it's not
fast enough for practical use for
instance humanoid just walked very
slowly it's good for experimental
evaluation on something but if you want
to use the humanoid in dynamic
environments like the real world i think
it wouldn't work the same thing can
apply to the autonomous driving the car
can't drive itself but if we put the car
on a traffic in the real world i think
it wouldn't work that's because so these
autumn our systems have to take care of
many processing seen VR time for
instance vision-based perception or
localization mapping matching a motion
planning of which is tracking learning
control and so on so these real-time a
pic applications have to go in parallel
every time so that figure is that just a
simulation that simulation still slow if
a stimulation is slow we cannot put
translate the applications into the real
world so this case so you can see cancel
the movie again you can see ya so I
don't know if you can see from there but
a car is deciding where to go so the
white object is a another car so it has
to avoid to hit so it decides I mean it
seeks for the line where the car can
drive on
so as we just looked these applications
are very heavy so definitely we need
some computing the scalability in the
computing power but let me show another
movie where we can see more easily the
computing power is definitely luck for
the up-to-date multimedia applications
so this is a collab collaborative work
with K university and Toto Schubert's
cooperation the product product is
actually shipped as also known as
toshiba cell TV so you can see the
interface is nice but if you carefully
look at the screen only that one TV show
which is focused can play but if you
want to have data interfaces people may
think if all TV shows on the screen can
play then that's better which is I
believe is a better interface but with
the current today's CPUs we couldn't do
that so instead we just gave up showing
all the TB in parallel instead we
decided to play only the one TV show
which is forecast so today I'm going to
talk about GPUs which probably can scare
up the computing power but before that
just let me give you some ideas what we
really need for Yetman computing because
even though you have a strong computing
platform if you do not care about real
time then we cannot build up the
applications so if you want to make
realize of real-time computing basically
you require to help timeliness and
timeliness is basically provided by
meeting deadlines which are directly
related to safety or quality and
interactivity and to meet deadlines you
need to prioritize tasks correctly and
also you need to isolate tasks strictly
but prioritization and isolation are not
easy stuff to realize so it may be a
little bit boring for you but it is
important to see how for instance
scheduling problems affect the
application so let's consider three
periodic tasks on two processes so this
is quite simple example and we assume
that these tasks are scheduled based on
just deadlines so if we have three tasks
to schedule if you think of media
players so media players basically
frames arrives almost periodically and
these frames want to be processed within
its period so here because we only have
two processors probably task one and a
task to would be scheduled first because
they have audio deadlines down tasks
three then after the frame what
execution of task one and task to
complete then tasks three can resume
here because we have two processors
probably one of the processors left
limit left on idle because we only have
one task to execute here then the task
one task to arrive for the next frames
they preempt tasks three because they
have earlier deadlines than task three
by the same token tasks three would
resume when the task one in a task to
complete but if task 3 has a long
execution time it would it would miss a
deadline even though we have many other
times to remain if you think of a little
bit better scheduling such your timing
variation can be easily avoided so for
instance i introduce deadlines in the
slack driven scheduling which change the
privatization policy a little bit but
this a little change significantly
improves the system's performance or
systems schedule ability so here
as the deadline driven scheduling we
basically execute the tasks based on
deadlines but we can provide some
functionality to Luke go ahead the
scheduling only one step next scheduling
point and in that case we can probably
predict if I mean which task may miss a
deadline and if we detect some task to
have a deadline is like this like this
case the task three would have a Miss
would have a deadline means if it is not
scheduled it immediately then we can
simply preferentially schedule the task
three first regardless over the
priorities or regardless of the deadline
so what I want to say here is
prioritization is basically very
important in timing critical systems so
that's what I'm going to talk about so
if we shift to mark larger scale of
computing platforms like GPU even though
we have a strong computing power if you
do not have any scheduling problem I'm
scheduling algorithms which can take out
the system to be schedulable you never
get the interactive the item systems to
be to be nice so here this is just
example how effective these scheduling
policies are so I test it oh sorry ah
it's some dirty but okay so i used
today's cpu to test if some scheduling
problems can affect the system
performance and in that case re imitated
the prototype of the toshiba TV so we
simultaneously play six high-definition
videos on the screen and the graph shows
the frame rates over the mainly focused
about as TV and if you do not care about
if you just simply use the deadline
based scheduling you actually see the
frame rates drop
significantly but if you use a little
better scheduling algorithm you can
basically improve the frame rates hmm
sorry this machine's actually not the
same one as I made a powerpoint but so
if you also take care of memory
management or networking then you can
even make this isn't better which I have
demonstrated in my previous work but so
if you focus on the test platform it's
just six videos on today's our Intel
CPUs which means to me CP performance
doesn't scale well so even though we
provide a good scheduling algorithm if
you play seven YT eight videos
simultaneously then your systems
eventually get messed up and such a
performance scalability issue would
apply more critically if you think of
father futuristic applications like 3d
online game computer vision 3d interface
and so on and this application domains
that actually is the one that I am very
interested in in my future work so i'll
direct to provide the solution how we
can scale up the performance for these
real-time systems so the question that i
am trying to address in my research is
how can we support data were compute
intensive applications I'm computing
well I believe that most of data
intensive are real-time computing or
data-intensive applications would
benefit from the computing power of
hardware accelerators so there are
mainly two types of how to accelerate as
as long as I know so one is GPU like the
one developed by developed by Nvidia and
the other type of hardware accelerator
is a so-called many core that the Intel
is trying to push
into the market well they are both
categorized into hardware accelerators
but they have different architectures
for instance GPU generally integrates so
many simply processing cores and in case
of nvidia geforce gtx 480 it includes
more than 400 cords on a chip on the
other hand in the case of Intel's
solution they embed only 32 cords but
these 32 cords are based on Intel's
architecture which means each single
processing cool is much powerful much
more powerful than any videos GPUs so
they adopt different solutions so
because they have different
architectures I believe we should have
different software architectures as well
and as the technology leads today we
actually run the operating system on a
cpu and from the cpu we control the GPU
on the other hand i have read some
couple of articles that proposed it
would be better to run the operating
systems on each core in case of intel's
menu architectures actually i'm not sure
quite sure how we can provide a solution
for many core because the many core has
not yet been in the market that's why in
marry such a young strictly focusing on
the GPU for now so today's talk let me
focus on a GPU so GPU is originally
developed for graphics processing and
but at the same time if you have a
program language support it can also be
used for general powers processing and
this is a simple formats comparison
between representative Intel CPUs and
NVIDIA GPUs
and if you regard the performance per
watt nvidia GPU is actually more than
five times faster than intel cpu and if
you don't care the performance a
performance per watt instead if you only
care the performance then any videos GPU
is more than ten times faster than the
spindle cpu so yes we have quite strong
computer architectures to scale up the
performance but the question here is
what about systems of care challenges
for these hardware accelerators and the
key observation which I have got from my
experiment is multitasking program so
GPU is you used to be used for
accelerating only one primarily
application like 3d game but if you
think of more complex applications like
autonomous driving or humanoids then you
want to run the multiple programs at the
same time and each of which needs to
have some timeliness but what happens if
so I run some experiments where I try to
execute a 3d game where other graphics
applications also running together and
here are you oops sorry I used two
different system software our GP drivers
device drivers one is nvidia official
driver and the other is an open-source
GP driver called nuvvu and i also used
two different GPUs one is a low-end
geforce and the other is a high-end GTX
and in all setups in all these scenarios
I actually encounter a significant
performance loss on the 3d game if some
other applications are running
background so the blue line blue box in
the
performance of the 3d game when it plans
with a low back load widget application
and let box indicates the frame rates of
the three yes just a very brief overview
of how the driver makes affects the
scheduling is the driver to basically
injecting low-level yielding commands
it's the strings going to GPU and
there's one drivers doing that
definitely not represent ah the
scheduling policy between I mean these
two the robots used almost the same
scheduling policies just send the GPU
commands in their arrival orders but
what I'm saying here is this is the
problem that's why I want to provide a
different solution so particularly so if
3d game runs with high workload graphics
application here I call it graphics bomb
then the performance the frame rates of
the 3d game drops even below 110 of the
case where the 3d game is running
standalone so actually I have identified
why such a performance penalty
performance loss what's post so the
first problem which I have found is
priorities and not affected at all on
the GPU because of drivers the second
problem which I haven't identified so
far is that there are non-preemptive
regions on the GPU so these two factors
actually disturb the 3d game while
multitasking program multitasking
execution system to have timeliness for
the overall applications here I can show
some simple example how priorities will
non-preemptive region affect the
system's responsiveness on the GPU so
assume that a high priority task like 3d
game or I was forced because the GPU is
either here so it can't
the GP commands to the GPU and the GP
commands can execute on the GPU but if
other activities also send the GPU
commands to the GPU while some other GPU
commanded GP one is executing on a GPU
they simply blocked and after the
preceding JP command completes then
these two pending GPU commands will
execute and regardless of priorities
regardless of any arrival patterns GPU
commands are just executed in the in
their arrival orders if you just use the
open source driver nvidia driver here
you can see that the priority inversions
is likely to happen so for instance here
a low priority pink task is executed
before the high priority blue task and
the same is true for the rest of the
diffusion and as a result high priority
task can be blocked by a low priority
task and this blocking time is actually
not bounded at all if for instance of
graphics bomb keep sending a huge size
of graphics command then a high priority
task can be blocked for long interval
scheduling software such as signature
task
that's what I'm going to talk about okay
um so here I made some abstraction quite
a simple abstraction but if you have a
closer look at the parallel GP
processing if you use the invidious old
architectures they only allow one
channel one GP kinetic is to execute at
the same time that's why I can abstract
the execution of GPU like a single
threaded a single set of execution but
if you use the anybody has new Fermi
architectures it can allow multiple
channels multiple contexts to execute at
the same time like here so therefore the
Fermi would improve the system over
system throughput eventually however the
problem is fundamentally the same so you
can see that still a high priority blue
task is affected by a low priority pink
task because we don't have any
scheduling nice scheduling algorithm in
the GPU driver so I'm going to talk
about how we can insert a scheduling
algorithm into the GP driver but before
that let me give you some concept of GP
driver model because as long as I know
NVIDIA has not yet released any detailed
documentation open you guys because you
are working at the myself so you may
have some collaboration and you may have
some documentation but in general we
don't know at all what individuals
driver or what GP software is doing
that's why i joined open source project
where we keep hacking the GPU keep for
instance keep sending some commands to
the GPU and just see the reaction and it
the project has lasted for three or four
years and finally we got
the precise GP driver model so we
actually identified what the invidious
what I was doing so that's what I'm
going to introduce here so applications
call API functions provide provided by
library and the library converts the API
functions to GP specific commands and
send them to the user space GP driver ok
and in the user space this procedure is
just repeated and at some point
userspace GP driver sends the system
call to the Canon space GP driver and
this Jeep Canada specific driver then
submits the commands but here the
command submission is not that the
kernel space GP driver submits oh sorry
yeah so here when the library converts
the GP specific command us to the GPS
Pacific Command and send them to the
user space GP driver it lights into the
memory mapped space in the colonel so
the space may be on the system ram well
the space may be on the video lamp
that's what is decided by the count
earlier the operating system but the GPU
command is written to the memory space
which is mapped from common space to the
user space so anyway then um when the G
userspace GPU driver sends a system call
to the contents of a strippa driver it
writes some packets to another space of
memory in the kernel space which is good
come on before so come on by pfizer ring
before and it keeps right a packet into
this ring before and each packet is
composed of buffer size and address
offset that point to the actual price of
GPU commands
then GPU is just these pockets so this
ring space being a buffer is accessible
GPU so the GPU can't lead the packets
then fetches the actual gpo grant groups
to the Internet GPU engines so the first
program which I introduced before so
this GPU command groups so GPU command
groups is a set of GPU commands so this
GPU command group suggesting secret in
their arrival orders + these deep you
command groups are non-preemptive
because they are a set of atomic
execution so under this constraint but
still we have to provide some solutions
to improve the timeliness for
data-intensive reason computing
therefore we provided we are proposed
some GPU scheduler so our gps scheduler
operates in the candidate space
coordinating with the original carnage
candidate a sleepy driver so we don't
need any changes to the user space so
the GPU command group suggests generated
as before same as before however when
the GPU command groups enters the GPU
commands submission interface in the
cannon specific driver the command group
is by a GPU commander schedule
are provided by / GG scheduler and
enqueued and instead the GP quantum GPU
command scheduler dispatches the GPU
command group issued by the most
important or a high priority task then
once the GP command group is submitted
by G pigment of schedule it just goes
through the same path as before and goes
finally goes to the GPU here when each
DPO command completes our GPS schedule
set up the GPU to generate an interrupt
from the GPU to the CPU and this
interrupt is relayed to the GPU commands
so that we can dispatch the next task so
basically what we are doing is it's to
provide the mechanism that can that
enables the GPU drivers to have the
scheduler as the operating system CP
scheduler that's so weak you GP quant
groups in a dispatch so the scheduling
policy is quite simple so when the GPU
is not idle just GPU command groups
attitude and when GPU gets idle typical
oops i dispatched based on priorities if
the GP command groups are executed under
this scheduling policy you can provide a
priority based institutions here are
some example so there are two tasks as
before with different priorities and
let's assume that high priority task
arrive is fast and it submits the GPU
come unglued fast so because JP is not
idle at this time so any GPU command
groups are cute when they are try they
are when a GPU driver tries to submit
even though the high priority task
arrives it is cute and because we set up
the GPU to generate an interrupt when
the preceding GPU command groups
completes the GPS scheduler can invoke
when the GPU one group the preceding GP
quanta group complete here because the
GPU scheduler nodes which command groups
are include so now when the GPU gets
either so that GPU scheduler dispatches
the GP one group based on the priority
in that case a high priority task can go
to the GPU fast then when ur G high
priority task completes on a GPU a low
priority task finally can go to the GPU
if you see here you can see that the
task is executions on the GPU up
correctly prioritized
so now we could provide the
prioritization for the GPU but
prioritization itself is just to
prioritize the tasks if some malicious
task keeps executing on a GPU it can
mess up the GPU resource again so that's
why we need to have some reservation
strategy for the GP as well the GPU is a
GP resource reservation that we
have proposed is to regulate the GP
resource usage and we can simply specify
the capacity which is allowed to be
spent on a GPU in a period p for each
task so if you imagine the linux control
group you can specify the execution time
in a period that are assigned to the
tasks using the Ducks control group so
let's assume there are two tasks again
and we assign the capacity C to one of
the tasks and when the system begins the
execution budget is initialized to see
for each task so in that case I mean in
this case we assume that the blue task
has the budget C and a period p and this
budget is decreased by the same amount
of the time that is spent by this blue
task on the GPU the scheduling is still
the same as the one I just introduced in
a previous price slide so it is executed
based on the priority however so because
as I said each GPU command group is
non-preemptive so if the execution
budget remaining education budget is not
enough to service the next GP one group
then the budget can be negative if we
just let the G pick one group to go go
to the GPU but that's fine our solution
we have two solutions here the first
solution it says soft so we allow
the budget to be negative however once
it gets negative we do not allowed the
task to go to the GPU even though it has
a higher priority than others because
the budget is not negative and this
budget isla perished at every period p
so at some point at some later point of
time the budget is replenished by the
amount of see now the high priority task
hi blue high priority blue task can go
to GPU finally eventually so there is
another reservation policy that we have
proposed is a hat the hard reservation
policy is more strict in a sense that we
can regulate the GPU resource must
strictly at the expense of of course
incurring overhead so in the hard
reservation every time the task go to
the GPU we check we predict how much
time the task would go to would spend on
the GPU due to time constraints I do not
explain how we predict the education
time of the GP quant group but the G big
money grip execution time can be
predicted based on some history so
because if you imagine like GPGPU
computing programs you open share
programs they use AP ice and the api's
each API generates a very similar
sequence of GPU commands so if we keep
the histories of the previous trip you
command groups we can somehow learn what
combination of GPU commands consume how
much GP time so we keep the history and
based on the history we predict the GPU
command execution time and if
the gpo command group execution does not
would not cause the execution budget to
be negative we let him go but however
when we predict the education time of
the task on a GPU then if we predict
that the execution budget would be
negative we do not allow him to go
because it may overload the GPU so
instead a lower low priority task can go
to GPU and like the soft GPU reservation
just I introduced in the previous slide
when the execution budget is lip
arranged by amount of see this high
priority blue task would be able to
eventually go to the GPU unless it
predicts I mean it is predicted that the
education budget is not going to the
negative value so here I tested some
performance interference to see how well
3d games are prioritized over and
isolated from competing graphics bomb so
as we saw in a previous slide if we do
not provide any timing support the
performance of 3d games is just messed
up but if you put high priority GPU hi
GP priority to 3d game you can
significantly improve the frame rates of
3d game and further if you use priority
and GPU hard reservation oh sorry soft
reservation then you can moreover
improve the frame rates of 3d games
because this case we limit the GPU
resource usage of background graphics
bomb to be ten percent and if your
father use how the reservation so soft
to the duration the GPU graphics form
our graphics film still could spend more
than ten pass
of GP resource because it's soft but if
you use hard reservation it never allows
the graphics bum to spend the execution
budget more than that it resolved so it
can provide a slightly better
performance so if we want to use the GPU
for the data intensive real-time
computing this property is very
important because you can guarantee that
your important programs running on a GPU
would not get affected by other
background jobs or other competing jobs
here I can show how well frame rates of
3d game can be and end a 3d widget
unregulated so we don't care how much
time the graphics poem spend but we
still care some widget applications like
if you imagine the 3d desktops then you
probably want to run you have to read
the game but you still want to have some
browser plugins or desktop components
based on the 3d graphics that they still
use the GP as well so in that case you
can regulate how much GP resource can be
used by each application so this case so
we set up the GP resource usage so that
the GP utilization becomes totally one
hundred percent so for instance if the
3d game is assigned ten percent of GP
resource the other competing 3d widget
is assigned ninety percent of GP
resource and if you scale the size of
this division then almost the 3d games
the frame rates of 3d game increase
proportionally which means the
reservation is actually working and same
is true for the other three ugh
3d widget so if the size of reservation
is decreased then the frame rates of the
3d vision is also decreased almost
proportionally so these are 3d games are
basically exhaustive so they try to
execute as fast as possible but we have
different type of applications in
particular for the item systems like
like a media player or any humanoids or
autonomous driving applications that
usually alive periodically and they want
to be processed within the period so if
we use the media player for evaluation
it actually matches for what we want to
achieve so here media player is
basically want to keep its frame rate to
be at 24 because this is the standard
definition for playing movie and if you
use priority support and the reservation
support for the movie player so we can
tightly guarantee that 10 player can
consume at the desired rate but if you
do not have priority or is a vision
support and if you just use the
invidious GP driver open so sleepy
driver then um player media player gets
affected and messed up so here by these
experiments we showed how much how
important to provide the priority and
reservation solutions for the GPU there
are some work in progress so we working
on fine grain finer grained GP resource
management or high-throughput GPU data
communication so let me show you how we
try to improve the granularity of
resource management for the GPU so the
GPU is actually a very complicated
architecture so GPU
eternity contains many engines I don't
know how many engines actually the
today's GPUs provide but at least we
know that the today's GPU like the one
provided by Nvidia they include graphics
engine power management engine and the
cone encryption decryption engine and
the context challenging and video
decoding engines and so on there are
many other engines inside the GPU but we
actually we do not fully understand how
many and what type of engines are
provided by GPU because Nvidia doesn't
release the documentation is open
however we know that every existing
engine on the GPU has a microcontroller
so microcontroller is like a CPU small
CPU it has own instruction set it has
code and data sections where some small
programs can execute and it also
provides interrupt or exception
mechanisms so we can basically run a
complicated I got complicated program if
the program size is small so the idea
here is why don't we install some
emitted OS inside the GPU so that we can
provide a final grain business
management so let me show you how we
actually install the operating systems
to the GPU so you fast right the
operating systems do as you like by
using the instruction sets provided by
microcontroller like this and you can
simply write this binary code into the
i/o port which is defined by the GP
itself so in my gtx 480 graphics card
has the i/o port at 0x proper bra so if
you like a code into this i/o port you
can basically install your own OS on the
GPU and once you write this binary code
are to the airport before you use the
GPU
your operating system will be activated
when you use the GPU and if we have own
operating systems on the GPU we can
provide finer grained for instance
scheduling so the previous example I
showed that we can somehow prioritize on
isolate the tasks executing on the GPU
but because each GPU quant group is
non-preemptive so for instance this case
even though we have a priority driven
GPU schedule at the device driver layer
if the high priority task arrives when
some low priority task is already
executing on the GPU it has to wait
until the preceding GP one group
completes on a GPU because this is
non-preemptive so if here in this
scenario if high priority task has
earlier deadline then the high priority
task may eventually miss the deadline
even though we have a prior to driven
scheduler at the best driver level so
what we are trying to do is to
coordinate with a microcontroller so
every time a task arrives and tries to
submit a GPU commands to the GPU it can
send some command packet to the
microcontroller through I you put
through a specific communication port so
there is some specific communication
port which is mapped by a GPU micro
controller itself to the system memory
so we can write some coma packet to this
area then the microcontroller can bid
which command is sent by a system CPU
side so every time a task arrives and
try to submit a GPU command we can let
notify the microcontroller of the
arrival of important task then we know
that from the microcontroller we can
save and load the GPU contexts like CPU
so we can basically provide a context
switch mechanism if you have own
operating system on the GPU
that's not expensive at all because
video memory and a GPU is connected by
very fast memory bus GD dl gddr5 so
about 50 100 gigabytes per second so
from the microcontroller you can just
adds the CPU that save all the contest's
to the video memory and you can load
another countries to the GPU okay so um
so in such a case if you switch to the
hyperactive task quickly then you have
more chance to avoid appliances and also
we know that the scaling voltage and the
frequency is also possible for the GPU
so as we already know we have many
algorithms for dynamic voltage and
frequency scaling so we can apply these
algorithms to the GP as well so when
some task arrives and tries to submit
the GPU commands to the GPU and if we
have a what low back road then probably
we can scale down the voltage and the
frequency of the GPU to save the energy
to save the power and combining with
context which we can probably provide
real-time power saving in a thermal
control at the same time and we already
have some experimental results but they
are not organized yet so i cannot show
on the slide here but we actually tested
these technologies are now possible for
the GPU right so we actually are trying
to use these fine grain GP Drusus
management for our project it's running
in Japan it's a green exact scale
computing project it's a collaborative
work with University of Tokyo and x axis
also Research Institute in Japan so it's
like exhaust scalar supercomputer we
developing exascale computer called k
of course its main goal is to realize
the post petascale computing but we also
trying to use the supercomputer for more
interactive and real-time use for
instance in Japan we have many
environmental problems like tsunami or
downpour last quake so we can probably
use the supercomputer what data center
to provide environmental forecasting
mechanism well to develop such a
supercomputer of course the GPU is one
of the best suited approaches because
it's computing scalability it's for now
much greater than that CPU so we have
plan to develop a gps cluster but
however making GP cluster has many
potential problems for instance
particularly in data communication so if
you want to make develop build up the GP
cluster you probably have a system like
this so each node has a GPU and CPU they
are connected by a pci interface and the
current state of the up state of art in
pci technology is just around 4 to 8
kilobytes per second on the other hand
GPU is connected with video memory by
gddr5 which is around 5 100 gigabytes
per second and also you can scale the
network as well if you use InfiniBand
and combine many InfiniBand links in
parallel then you can actually even
achieve the perform eunuch ations
throughput over 100 year bytes per
second so which means we have a
bottleneck on the pci communication so
if so there are some technologies that
support GPU data communication like
Nvidia and the mellanox have a solution
called GP direct but it's still not
fast enough from my viewpoint so here
the example shows some put a bottom
problematic GPU communication so if we
recipe data from the network and this
data needs to be processed on a GPU but
because we have to copy the data to the
place where the GPU can access the
current solution is that so the data is
copied to main memory fast because the
nic driver has a receive buffer on the
main memory but GPU generally want the
data in video memory so it has to copy
the data to the video memory to process
so there is at least one copy to be post
and before the Nvidia and the mellanox
solution there is another copy from the
main memory to the main memory because
GPU still has to have the data in the
main memory where it can access but the
nic driver doesn't know we're in the
main memory the GPU can access so there
was another make a copy from main memory
to main memory and any media and the men
are dogs have some collaborative work to
reduce this unnecessary copy then they
reported that forty percent of
throughput improvement what's provided
but still memory to memory copy is post
at every data communication so we try to
even remove this copy and so we are
studying why we needed this additional
copy at every data communication and we
well simply identify that that's because
Nick driver and the GP driver or
developed independently so that's why
they cannot communicate with each other
so what we are doing is so when we
receive data from the network what we
want to do is to copy
video memory directly because if we can
do this then the data communication
throughput will be improved
significantly so a problem is how we can
do this so basically there are three
address spaces that relate to the GPU
communication so one is I you address
space which is used by PCI communication
and there is main memory space and also
video memory space and a GP drivers
basically map the address space to its
own space for instance the enemy Diaz
official GP driver maps a part of PCI
space to its memory mapped registers so
because we map these i/o memory-mapped
registers to the PCI space we can
control the GP from CPU and also nvidia
driver maps the GPU processing data to
the member PCH region so the CPU can
write the GPU commands to this space
then finally this GP processing data can
be copied to the video memory so there
is a mapping problem so you can map the
PCI region either a memory or video
memory an immediate solution is they map
the i/o registers because they do not
access these registers frequently so
they came up to the main memory which it
takes longer time to access but it's ok
because they do not access to the IU
registers frequently but in on the other
hand GP processing data need to be on
video memory because they use they are
used very frequently so every time the
GP who tries to compute something they
have to access this data so because we
can map the PCI region like this we can
do when we can do that when we receive
the data from network we can have a
receive buffer no
only on this main memory but we can have
we can point to the PCI are you address
space as a Red Sea buffer so because
Nick driver has that direct memory
access controller and we can tell the
address pull the red sea before by the
pci address space then every time data
receives a data is coming nic driver
just writes the data to this space which
means if we write the data to this space
because this face is mapped to the video
memory it can directly copy to the video
memory so because actually infiniband is
quite complex communication standard so
i didn't we didn't try with the integral
infiniband yet but we actually evidence
that we can do this direct GP data
communication with each on it so when
which means we believe that we can do
the same make it make the same mechanism
with using more faster InfiniBand gold
records oh that's a protocol problem so
what we showed here is we can directly
copy the data from main memory a story
driver space to the video memory space
but yes we need some protocol stack
implementation-specific for two GP data
communication or I can skip this so um
so so there is another project running
in parallel so we can apply the same
idea to different domains for instance
3d video so 3d video is a 3d pictures
that can be seen from any directions so
3d TV you can just see the reject from
the front but 3d video you can see from
any directions and we are collaborating
with CMU's robotics Institute
and also killed University yeah we can
skip this so basically a 3d video
streaming we need to set up camera and
we need to capture the video from
multiple viewpoints then we need to
reconstruct the object and will be
july's you'll be checked finally we can
send it to the screen so this is this
needs to be done in the air time so it's
a again very heavy computational
application and the CMU group is trying
to use a GPU but I'll they first tried
to use the CPU but they couldn't make
everything in the air time so they were
forced to have offline calculation
because of because the computing power
was luck so they're now trying to use
the GPU but still we have a problem in
communicating between the GPU nodes so
we are happy now having a collaborative
collaborative work so that's more I
guess significant to have a direct
communication because when you receive
the data from camera we can hear
directly copy the data to video memory
then we can again directly copy to the
Nick when the data needs to go to the
stream so if we do not have a direct
communication mechanism you have to copy
to the main memory fast then from main
memory you have to copy data to the
vizio memory again when you want to send
data to network you have to copy to the
main memory fast yes okay so we will be
district communication mechanism is more
significant for these 3d video streaming
applications Kirsty we have scheduling
and memory management problem problems
what we need to specify some driver AP
is because if we have heuristic
implementations then each driver needs
to have different you know different
implementation but we want to provide
some dry by PS specification for GPU
direct communication so that we
easily develop a GPU our I old rivals
hmm ok so the memory management is so
problematic because video memory is a
limited space so if our video memory is
already used you cannot basically
allocate data so imagine the CUDA
programming if you try to malach the
data more than the size of video memory
the malach just fails so the first idea
that we should provide at least is we
need to some swapping mechanism between
main memory and the video memory so that
we can use more and larger space of
memory but still we need to copy the
data fraud to evict to the data from
main memory to the ad from the video
memory to memory so the overhead is
imposed on the application so what we
are trying to do is we always try to
keep some space not used so because we
keep the space left unused when the
application won't Stella Kate the data
on the video memory it can easily of
course allocated data and because GPU
execution is independent from the CPU
execution so we can make another space
by copying by victim some data from the
memory to main memory while GPU
executing some commands so which means
we can hide the performance overhead in
post on data copy so summary so in this
research we showed that prioritization
and isolation are possible for GPU
accelerated applications
challenging issues what we are trying to
address for now is a fine-grain GP
resource management that can provide I
think better timeliness for
data-intensive real-time computing and
also we think it's possible to make
realize of high-throughput GP community
PU data communication but of course GPU
is not much known the GP architecture is
not much known because Nvidia does not
have any available open source
documentation so we need more in-depth
investigation for the GPU and as well as
more generic many architects judge that
we believe the market would have in the
future in future vision so Google is
actually driving I mean developing
autonomous card so they are Google
actually took some people from CMU and
Stanford and they made their own
development team with the autonomous
driving and I found some interesting
article so the first article which I
thought very interesting is so G google
CEO said it's a bug you know the cars
were invented before the computers so
you count your car basically should
drive itself because just make sense and
I quite agree with him because if we
have a computing technologies before the
car was developed then we could have
more intelligent because by now and the
other article which I found from the
Google's source is Sebastian it's a
Stanford professor but he's a
distinguished Google engineer so he said
autonomous driving each technologies are
all made possible by Google's datacenter
which can process are the numerous
amounts of information gathered by
their cars so which means they trying to
make use of their data centers
technology and embedded ultimus
computing ultima sir I mean computing so
because I also have the same background
so my boss I mean my project running in
the Japan it is for exec el computing at
the same time I also have another
project that I am involved in at CMU is
about autumn as driving so it is it is
going to be very interesting to combine
these two different domains of research
so for instance you can provide whole
areas of the United States to each
ultimate it ultimately the car so that
they can drive from eastern coast to
western coast but these are
communication and data processing need
to be done in real time so it's a
challenging issue which I am very
interested in and eventually maybe we
can develop some intelligent autonomous
driving car yeah that's all thanks
the scheduler that you yes uh
technically yes but we have submit the
idea to some conference which is double
blind so I guess we can make it open
after we get yeah that's not really I
mean organized open source project which
everyone can download from our website
traditional yes but new ball is a soap
open source project but they do not care
about real time but instead we
another project from Nouveau where we
take care of more interactive winter
real-time use and this another project
actually the project is very willing to
use the solution for real-time computing
so hopefully by next year we can
implement integrate our solution the
open source project
the father's horse management yes there
is some overhead associated with that
right I was you need to gather the
statistics about the previous to be
commands yes then we predict right
did you try to estimate like terms of
federal agency war for CPU usage like
how much it is actually a hard
reservation it's time-consuming it's not
that much time consuming for practical
use but of course it impose
computational overhead but we in terms
of trivial operations as a drop total
like let's say time bomb was the
kind of total operations the primary
applications is not affected about
because because the prediction is going
on for instance graphics that
performance of the graphics form can be
you know decreased by predicting the
commands but so you don't want to use
hide reservation for instance for widget
application but widget application is by
nature not supposed to affect the
primary application so much so we can
use instead soft reservation but
graphics poem or any other unknown
alicious applications probably we can
use has reservation and once we verify
that the application is not malicious
then we can switch the software
something like we can change the
scheduling or reservation policy on
demand but if you have any chance for
the application being malicious then you
want to use the hard reservation so that
we can strictly limit the GPUs resource
usage of the application I was thinking
you have the zeros yes have this dislike
they're expensive since you're already
doing some prediction
could you just do something to get rid
of the error using the prediction yes
but what happens if the prediction is
not precise yes it can be non precise
I'm in prison yeah 3x like yes this
possible when it's an interrupt fires
and bottles full an empty warm and spice
context
I exceed me when you drop fire up but
when during buffer is fully empty war on
space so it's a tricky so there is a GPU
command that generates the interrupt so
we money on purpose as a set of actually
three commands up at the end of each GP
command group so that so every time yeah
more questions
okay thank you